Okay.
Here I am with Into Carpenter on March
3rd, 2026, in Bloomington, Indiana.
And my name is Julie Stout,
and we are here today
to discuss the part two of our interview,
which is the Dawson Gary Project.
And Richard Dawson himself.
So thank you again
for joining me for this.
And if you have anything you want to say,
I can start with the first question.
Okay. Start with the first question. Okay.
That'll work.
Regarding your first involvement
with the project,
how did you become connected to the Dawson
Gary Project?
When, where and in what capacity?
Well, it was probably out on our farm.
I have, for some reason,
think that he came out there
to talk about it, but I'm not sure
that doesn't really matter.
It was I was at that point a research
assistant to him, to Doctor Dawson and.
So this was offering me a part time job.
I don't think it was a full time job.
I don't really remember that either.
To join the Gary Project
as a coordinator of
of what's going to happen there.
And we certainly none of us knew
what was going to happen there.
Six people were going up for six weeks.
For two years, over two years
over the period of two years.
And there would be
a conference at the end.
Was this in 1975 or sooner?
It was 1975 to 77,
and he had gotten the funding
from the National Endowment
for the Humanities,
and then at that point got it through
Indiana and it was ready to go. And,
then he invited the students,
I think, as well.
How did he go about choosing these
students who would work on the project?
I wish I knew, but I don't I really don't,
he wanted the variety of ethnicity
and students who were competent
in doing different kinds of things
with all of us worked with the Lithuanian
community, which was significant
in the region, in one of the cities there.
So she had a good handle on that one.
Plus there are
very, very many Lithuanians.
And in Chicago.
So they kind of were connected,
I think, in terms
of their cultural activities,
they would go up to Chicago to do stuff.
I don't not sure that anybody came down
to the region to do things,
but I could be wrong.
And Richard March
worked with Croatian himself
and was able to also work with,
Serbians.
He was a musician as well.
So he could do that, work with them.
They were quite a musical culture,
as most of the ethnic are.
I think.
So there was that.
And, John
Hassler was an ethnic musicologist,
and I'm not sure that he was connected
to any particular.
He wanted to find
what up there was of interest
to him,
I would think, in terms of, ethnicity.
I think he ended up working with
I would not even going to try to remember.
Philip George was working with Mexicans.
He spoke Spanish and
he had already done.
I think some of these folks
were already getting ready to work
on their dissertations themselves.
So there was that too,
that they were very involved.
This would expand what they knew.
And when we left out Phil
through, Eli Cooley
would work with African-Americans
and Adrian Seward
the same way with African-Americans.
So am I leaving somebody out?
Not that I can remember.
But at any rate, they were all sooner.
So closer or farther away
from finishing their degrees.
When I was in the archives,
I noticed that there were like student
papers of certain, like oral
history accounts that they collected.
Were there also undergrads
working on this project or other
grad students besides these that, you.
Know, idea? Yeah.
It was also related to different
ethnic groups as well,
but they aren't the names that you listed.
And so I was curious, and I was
maybe you knew about other connections
to that area
in particular.
What do you mean by that?
I don't understand,
The fact that I found, like, different
like, accounts in the same, like,
northwest region of Indiana,
but they were not the grad students here
that you mentioned.
They were like they were labeled
as student skilled work, like files
where they, transcribed
oral history accounts and oral
literature accounts
of, like, different, folklore practices
or, folktales or something of the like,
revolving around different ethnic groups.
However, these materials were in the,
Indiana University in Northwest.
Where they had active classes up there.
Our students would go up there
as and and earn money,
and they would get people involved.
I do not know who those who were.
In my class or something.
Then they had and they had a class
during the Gary Project
that Dawson was teaching,
which room was where I was reminded about
and reading the book.
So maybe as students in this class.
And there was a student in there
who really attached to the project,
eventually came down to IU
and started a degree
and worked with me later on a
an editing project.
I can look her name up, but she's
she's got a that would be fascinating
to get a hold of her.
To talk to her about it.
Yeah, because she grew up there.
She grew up in the rich area.
That actually puts the pieces together.
If it was Dawson's
class that he taught up there, and he also
sent his students out to do field work.
And maybe that's
where those files came from
and how that's
how they're connected to that area.
They somewhere
in this book I think John has to
is the one who does it.
He lists.
No it might be Tom Adler.
That would be good
if it was Tom Adler because
he lists everything that was deposited.
Well not everything,
but he said so many tapes, so many,
interviews, so many whatever you know.
Transcript.
And I will be reading that as well. So.
And hopefully you'll find it.
Yeah, I will find that. Yeah.
Okay. Great.
Leading into the the next question,
what were your roles and responsibilities?
What were your primary responsibilities.
And role, if at all?
Did they change over time?
But have a big question.
I found that my primary,
responsibilities in the beginning
were to deal with the Indiana University
administration.
Which turned out
to be a terrible job
because they weren't familiar
for some reason
at that point with this sort of a project.
And so for them,
they just sort of rolled their eyes and,
and we had to figure out
how we were going to pay
the people, how we were going to pay
for our transportation.
We had to rent cars. We,
in order to have ways to get around.
And we had to buy the equipment
and they didn't really know
what equipment to do, and we didn't know
anything about equipment.
So that in itself was a huge problem.
Apparently.
That stopped us for a while.
And then ultimately when we did this movie
about Jenny's Cafe, where mostly
the Serbians
or Croatians were, were playing music,
and it was but I think both went both,
both ethnic communities
participated in Denny's and we ended up
eating there a good bit too.
But we ended up it was beyond us.
We ended up using the IU, television
people to do that
for us.
So they went up to Gary
as well. Record it?
Yeah, to record it.
It wasn't, I wasn't I don't know who was.
Jenny's and Gary.
I don't remember now where Jenny's was
but they.
Went I wasn't Gary.
Yeah.
Maybe so
Because the documentary still exists
and some of the recordings used in
the documentary is actually housed in
IU archives as well.
And I was able to listen to that
and listen to the bands and, and play
and everything.
And there were, I think two interviews
also recorded in the cafe as well.
Do you know,
would that be Richard Mark who?
I think so, so many.
What was
what were your other responsibilities
despite, the challenges
that you had before,
the fieldwork was actually done
with the equipment,
with the cars, with the payments.
What was your role like during it?
How did you actually serve
as like coordinator for the students?
Probably whatever they they needed.
And I was not up there all the time.
I went up at certain times and did
participate in some of the interviews,
but that was just because that happened
at the moment, and it made sense
for one reason or another.
I made contact with the archivist.
I think up there
I got to know those people.
I might have I probably had to
find housing for them.
Some of them found housing in and,
some of the people that they met,
they were able to go back up and meet
and just stay at their house.
But mostly it was it was a couple
of hotels or or motels and.
Yeah.
And I might have arranged that. Yeah.
Whatever,
whatever needed to be done logistically,
I imagine that that, that, that first year
and then once the fieldwork was over,
then it was more working with, with
how is this going to get transcribed?
I don't think that was up to the students
themselves.
That's where we hired work study students
and organizing that in Bloomington.
Once all the tapes came back and
and also talking
to how how they were going to be,
I don't know why we did.
We did.
Oh, initially deposit them up there
because that seemed
like where they should.
Be in northwest. Yeah.
And then IU northwest
decided that it was above,
above their pay grade
because they really hadn't didn't have
the same sort of anything
as you might have.
And that explains the split
in the collection as well.
There have been more recent talks
on how we can,
collate this collection
into one, repository.
Then we'll see what happens with that.
But that discussion is still ongoing.
Well, I was very struck as I was reading
everything that they were doing
and everything that
about the region that they were saying
and about the United States, really,
because it was important
what was up there.
Things were going things were going weird.
You know,
the steel mill was was going to eventually
not be there anymore.
And you could begin to see that Gary.
Gary went way downhill during those years.
It's an important project for history.
And I was sad as I was reading it,
that I don't think that it got used
very much either in the classes here,
but I could be wrong.
I don't know how we would find that out
if once those transcripts were done,
did anybody use them?
The classes were taught on, on urban
folklore.
In fact,
that became more and more important.
I think, over time. And they're
they're certainly talking about,
well, what is urban folklore exactly.
And they're, they're speculating on it
as, as they do the field work.
They're but I don't think
it was used very much at all.
But I could be wrong.
What was the extent of the
how long were urban folklore
classes taught to your knowledge
after this project?
And that's the exact question.
Yeah, yeah, I really don't know.
I know that, yeah.
I mean, Linda, Linda possibly did, Dawson
possibly did was alive for another,
well, almost ten years.
So he might have taught those classes
that can be looked up.
I don't know.
I mean, the students graduated,
they went on.
I don't know how many of them were taught,
how many of them
were doing
other kinds of projects for money.
How many had, fellowships or whatever.
To do more stuff with it?
It's worth asking,
when I speak, when I try and speak
for other students as well, I can ask them
how their work in this project
affected their career trajectory
and how they want to represent
any type of urban folklore in their work.
When I mean, yeah, once they.
Heard, yeah, how.
They went, how they graduated and,
I mean, I
don't know, Eli Cooley
and Adrian Seward became faculty members.
Elinor did not,
she I think a lot of them
were became public folklorist.
So they would have used them
maybe differently from classroom.
From classroom materials and teaching.
So worth asking.
This leads me into the beginning
of the project
in terms of goals and scope,
what were the project's aims at the start
and how did those things
evolve?
Well,
there was clearly no map
for how it could evolve.
Everybody got together for a while.
They had they had, team meetings.
It was hard to get together
people for team meetings because everybody
was living down here in Bloomington
until they got up to the region.
They had appointments that they had made
at the point that any meeting
would have been announced. So,
there it was, a
changeable number of people who met,
but they did meet
and they certainly
I got the feeling from what they wrote
and from what I remember, that it was
there were good discussions
about what
each each person was, was experiencing
and how that was different or the same
from what everybody was experiencing.
Pretty much,
I think they were all fairly fascinated.
They they helped each other more
and more as they began to see
how they could help each other, began
to understand what people were doing,
and the equipment brought them together
to because people needed help.
For the students.
Yeah, they needed help,
you know, to be out in the in the region,
the learning, learning those
the equipment was new for everybody,
which in
itself is
amazing because you're meeting strangers
and you're also asked
to, you know, don't document them.
And that's not so simple
to, have people be photographed.
And who are you?
Was this technology
knew at the time as well?
Oh, yeah.
It was like brand.
And it was huge.
You got it was huge.
So nothing like now.
You could probably do it
all with our phones.
Completely different.
And them too.
I think that
when you think about the atmosphere,
I mean the region had a bad reputation
going going up.
They knew that,
I think that once they were up there,
they it wasn't an issue anymore for them.
For most of them, they knew where to be
careful and and what to do.
But at the same time, with the reputation,
especially that Gary had and Gary at
that point was almost entirely black,
to go out and and ask
to take pictures, ask questions,
put this huge equipment
out on a, in one place.
There's a picture of of it
going on a sidewalk.
People are going by,
they don't know what this is.
It's not simple for the
for the field workers.
Do you remember students telling you
anything about their experiences as well?
What they were feeling when they were
trying to do the field work?
I wish I did.
Do, did Dawson
say anything about the process
at all, about how the project evolved
or how maybe differed
from what he imagined it to be?
I I'm sure he did.
I'm sure you had many thoughts on it.
I'm sure the only possibility is that
I did keep my own notes.
So possibly in there if I ever find them,
I will tell you if I can find anything.
It's just my curiosity, that's all.
But, the interesting viewpoint
that you have in
perspective on this is that you are
kind of like a bird's eye view on,
you know, how much work
it took to get the materials,
the equipment and the logistics behind it.
And so you also knew what challenges
that were posed to the students
and everything.
So you have a different perspective
in that regard to,
do you have anything
else you'd like to add for that part?
Okay.
Next question is about the institutional
and community context.
How does the project fit within IU
and the broader community at the time.
It didn't fit.
It didn't fit in.
That's what all the challenges were trying
to convince people or anything.
I think that, folklore in this case
especially,
you're going up to the region,
you're taking students with you, you're
you're organizing all this paperwork
to take them up there.
You're buying equipment
for thousands of dollars.
I mean, it was,
Yeah,
it was
it was something, I think, for all of us
that Dawson's imagination
had maybe gone too far.
Even though he had the NIH grant funding.
This. Do
you think he still faced, like, backlash
from IU itself to even do the project?
No, I don't think so.
It's just that when it gets to the people
who have to do the, the, the,
the payment, you know, the paperwork, then
they usually just
get something for somebody
to go and write a book,
or a scientist to do something.
But for us to go up to the region
and ask for
for what we did, I think that was
that was well, I suppose
radio and television
would have had similar things.
So. For documenting and everything,
Then I did meet some of the people
who worked with more with,
with things like
photo and, and,
yeah.
But I just, I, I haven't
where I have been something
that I wrote myself
in the beginning of this about the
how difficult it was to,
Let's see.
Yeah.
Let me, let me read some of this later.
And so we don't slow it up. No.
No worries.
It's okay now to.
Yeah. Go ahead.
Oh, equipment problems continue to plague
us throughout the fieldwork period.
After weeks of relying on
phone and memo for our various requests
and needs, I finally decided to adopt.
Whenever feasible, the person
to person approach
the tactic is more time consuming,
but nevertheless a success.
The impersonality of university offices
is rarely broken through.
Everyone is hidden by the phone and
by the yellow memo or or blue requisition
so that was
that was it that it was just unusual
for what they usually do?
I called,
but even if the person is
if even if the person reached
knew the answers,
I did not always come away informed.
For instance, I called about university
car rental charges,
asking specifically
what was the cost per mile.
I did not think to inquire
whether any additional charges
were involved,
and only months later wasted money.
Wasted money.
Later did I learn about hourly rates?
And then, because I at last
knew the question to ask.
So it was a real initiation
for me about what's behind the university.
And university policy.
And, yeah.
Now that the material is gathered,
we have all entered yet
another stage of the project
during weekly meetings.
So we did meet.
We as
we are assessing our materials
and comparing and refining our findings to
come up with useful generalizations,
both about
urban fieldwork and urban folklore,
as well as about specifics
about folklore in the region.
Half a dozen work study
students are helping us transcribe
tapes, organize and archive
the collected materials,
which will be deposited in the Indiana
University Folklore Institute archives.
All of us are looking at the accumulated
transcripts, videotape, slides, artifacts
with an eye to transforming them
into materials that can be used in, into,
into introductory folklore courses,
as well as in advanced seminars
on urban folk or somewhere along the line.
During the past 18 months,
someone described us as a
gangling, bright, clumsy
adolescent of a project.
By the end of August 77,
we hope to have come of age.
So that's what I end at. But it does.
It does remind me that the the the videos,
individual videos that mark that,
Richard March
especially did with the Serbian,
the Hostler and the other ghost whose lore
those were used in classes
that Jenny's project was used in classes.
Right after.
But I don't know what those classes
might have been.
Maybe some of the large classes
for undergraduates, for example.
That could have been.
Would you be able to say for the,
like, recording
what book you just read from and who was.
Yeah, that was,
This is called Indiana Folklore
Journal of the Hoosier Folklore Society,
volume ten, number two, 1977.
And I read from
folklore in the Calumet Region
from my article and to Gail Carpenter
coordinating an Urban Folklore Team
project.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Just because I know people can't see
when they listen to this. That's right.
Yeah, exactly.
Is there anything you'd like to add
about the
how it fit in
with the community at the time?
Because the.
The community up. There.
Yeah, in, northwest Indiana,
there's a lot happening in that time.
Steel mills.
I know there's some civil rights happening
during that time to.
I think for Adrian and Ellen,
it might have been the, the,
the most challenging.
And maybe for.
Maybe for everybody
because things were happening right.
Things were happening up there and the
region was changing as well.
Some of the cities were
people were moving out into fancy
neighborhoods and development,
even if they didn't have furniture
for the house that they had just bought.
I mean, that was one of the things
that people were talking about.
Yeah, they
they got it, but have nothing in it.
It's empty.
So but I don't remember.
And even as I read through,
nobody seemed threatened,
which they might have been something
that they really wondered.
Because we were out at night,
we were in the dark.
We were parking cars somewhere
in order to get some place
from one place to another.
We probably went in pairs a good bit.
They they needed help.
They helped each other.
They really did.
So this to.
Me, because the equipment was really heavy
to begin with as well.
Yeah.
And and because they were finding that
they maybe had some,
some common interest in a particular,
project.
Each of the students selected
what they wanted to do.
I was surprised by that.
There weren't
there weren't really surveys,
so much at all.
They picked separate, separate topics.
I mean, Adler talked about,
he took a lot of pictures,
and he incorporated
the topics of those pictures
and the themes of those pictures,
into his talking about the equipment.
So they even
here's Jenny, for example,
and he made comments about it
in Richard March with the
he concentrated on that timber.
It's a tradition.
And probably
the closest to
something like a survey was Phillip
George with the tails of the Puerto Rican.
And he went to Puerto Rican.
He didn't really go,
Mexican.
So they were free to think about
what they wanted to do and document,
and what they wanted
and, inland to produce.
Surprisingly, I remember this, vaguely
chose
to talk about a hermit, an urban hermit
who had had
some,
Some tragic
things happen in his life, and he,
he just walk the walk the neighborhood.
He had a certain route that he walked,
and his beard grew longer and longer over
the years.
Was her focus more of a,
like, invisible person?
Almost like someone I know.
He was very.
In fact,
I could still look him up and very.
Visible and.
Very visible. Very remember memorable.
Yeah.
I was very surprised how much,
he was alive online.
And I thought that
she would report on the Lithuanians
but did not.
And it says with to this
the duties to the.
Who would do this for duties.
Of the duties. The duties.
I don't think he did it in in the region.
His his his job was afterwards.
Why don't know why.
Why did we hire him?
We hired him for some reason and.
I thought he did some of
those or any and community.
Did the work.
With the Lithuanian community.
He did.
But he did that in Chicago later
and most of the rest of his life.
Really, he's still doing it.
But in the beginning he'd had a different.
Role.
Potentially.
Well, Dawson Dawson lost the names of the,
of the field workers.
And I remember
he does say what what it is that
the Judas rehired him
for something special,
but I don't remember what it was.
He was in the office
a lot in an informal globe building.
And you are looking
for the land of the mill rats right now.
Written by you?
Yeah. See?
To what he says about it.
To recount my meandering field strategies.
This is Dawson
writing in the first chapter of.
Or the first or the preface
of The Land of the mill.
That would require a separate report.
Suffice to say that for six months
during 75 and 76,
I lived in the region,
interviewed in tape, recorded at citizens,
attended civic events
so he would know, in in
probably in subsequent questions in
here are about the steel mill.
And I think also the the churches
and I think maybe the government.
So toured
steel mills, visited black
and ethnic churches and entered
as much as I could into the life
of the region to establish a base.
I twice, twice taught a course
on folklore, an oral history
of the Calumet Region
at Indiana University Northwest in Gary,
with the idea
of enlisting students in the project.
So there are your interviews.
Some proved to be excellent informants
and collectors and good friends.
From time to time,
each of the seven doctoral candidates
in the folklore department in Bloomington
participating in the project
under our grant from the NIH,
drove up for limited
stays to conduct special inquiries
according to their expertise,
and aid me in the endeavor
to fathom the folklore
or mysteries of the region.
Adrian Seward and Gil Cooley, now
Ellen Cooley, concentrated on the blacks,
Richard March on the Serbs and Croatians,
or Leonard Bourdon, US and Lithuanians
and Philip George on the Latinos,
Tom Adler on the southern whites
and the equipment,
John Hassey on black gospel music.
Richard the
duties a graduate student
who was a native of Gary,
I forgotten that assisted
with the video equipment.
So he went out in the field with them
all proved invaluable field
count collaborators.
And that does reflect
mostly what the records show as well.
And especially, you mentioned Thomas Adler
taking a bunch of pictures
there, some around different themes.
I recently scanned a lot of those
pictures, actually, because there are
multiple files on the pictures
I took in the field for that.
Yeah.
You know.
Okay, okay.
Do you have anything else
you'd like to say about the community or,
how you've been on you before? You know.
I think they got pretty involved
in the community and, John
Hassey in here has a, has an interview
that he does with one of the black
ministers in Gary,
and he really talks about Gary itself
and how how the Baptist
community and the,
Methodist communities
are different in terms of class.
And so I think they
they got into it as well,
what the community was all about.
Okay.
Moving on to my next question,
about the collaborators and partners
who were the key
people or groups that you worked with
and what did each contribute?
That's actually feeds right
into what we just talked about.
So unless you want to add anything.
No I don't think so.
Yeah, I think.
They're they they're connected.
And you know, and what they wanted to do
video tapes
of connected them to other things as well
therefore.
So the Jenny's
larger
video thing.
About how this larger project
kind of starting to like micro projects
within this larger.
Exactly.
And then took us back to IU
where we needed the expertise
of the, radio and television department
to help us.
With to help you with that.
Makes sense.
So we knew when we were ready
to do something like that.
Especially
when the technology is quite new.
I can understand that is such a struggle
to for me and everything.
And it very
quickly somebody mentioned
and something I read very quickly.
It was it turned old.
So it became difficult to work
with the kind of videotapes
that we, that we recorded.
Because the technology
was constantly changing and.
Constantly changing.
Which leads me inadvertently
into my next question, which I know.
We talked a bit about the methods
and practices you mentioned.
The equipment,
but is there what other approaches,
did the project use, such as field
work, documentation or archiving?
And why? Which?
Well, it was all field work.
And interviewing.
Ellen was, was
was fascinating to all of us because he,
he chose to work with voodoo
and that involved some,
some delicate talk to, to women
because part of
the way that they supposedly,
bewitch their, their lovers
is to take out stake and wear it
during menstrual periods.
And that made, made it magic interesting.
Yeah, it was interesting.
And the women were here.
So here's a stranger walks in a young man
and he wants to know about this.
And she's, you know, who knows what age.
Remembering this as opposed
to being one of the young lovers.
And, she's very reluctant
to use those words.
So working with certain like, in group
communities
would be kind of difficult
to, like, actually get information from.
Yeah.
So I think you had to learn the,
the delicacy of, of interviewing,
interviewing people.
It's not always straightforward
and involves some things
that are unusual to most of us.
And then how do you deal with it?
I would guess I'm just guessing on this.
Having being familiar
with the Latvian, community
of refugees at that time.
That Elena might have chosen
not to do her writing about them
because there's a lot of sensitivity
so that you had to think about that, too.
So she writes about the Urban Hermit
instead.
Yeah.
So there were there were things they were
they were very conscious
of and tried to be very careful about.
They were good field workers.
In other words,
I think we all thought that.
The Dawson
knew that this project would be deposited
into an archive beforehand.
Or was that this idea or.
I would think so.
He was all about archives.
You know, at that point we had six,
graduate.
What do you call them?
They had,
assistants for the archives.
Six people had money to work
in the archives.
To specifically examine this project, you.
Know, just to work.
Out and work in the archives. Right.
So that went into it, and they.
So students
eventually got on to that as well. But,
but it's just amazing because
we don't have anything like that anymore.
Yeah.
It's gone. It's very different now.
The support is very different.
Do you think that the knowledge
that this would be archived
changed anyone's approach to fieldwork.
Would it be in the archive.
Knowing that it would be archived
after the project.
I think.
Everybody assumed
it would be in an archive.
Folder.
Anything they did would inadvertently be.
They knew that it would be like the
the public
would consume this in the future.
And I think.
So because,
I mean, also they weren't transcribing
as far as I know, they may have chosen
to transcribe certain things
maybe they were going to write about,
I don't know,
but we wouldn't have hired
all the other transcribers.
Yeah.
Is there anything else you'd
like to add
about the approach to the project?
Remind me again
what you said, the approach.
What approaches to the project use
and why,
like field work
documentation on the on having.
An authentic
with field work, but also, the video.
The video. Yeah.
The video on that.
Yeah. The,
The cameras, the recorders.
Right.
And the field work,
of course, included, special events
like festivals and so on to
that were important
to the community.
But, yeah,
okay.
I'm just trying to see if I can find
where
somebody wrote down all this.
How much?
That maybe that was Tom Adler.
Those are the ministers.
You know, here's the psychics in
the region is what Ellen calls.
Who's.
Conversations about who do.
I didn't get those.
I just saw ridiculous of it the other day.
Gary's black self-image, Adrian Seward.
So that should be good.
And, she was good at doing it.
And a black urban philosopher,
Adrian Seward,
this is from the,
Folklore and the Calumet Region book,
but I can maybe it was Tom Adler.
Well, anyway, let's go on.
Okay,
I know that you mentioned,
Ellen Cooley, who is also Gilbert Clark,
and he took into account
the fact that he was
you had to be delicate with his interview
because he was asking,
people about very specific information
that maybe they're not comfortable
sharing with strangers.
Which leads me
right into ethics and consent.
What how were ethical considerations,
handled, such as permissions,
confidentiality, or community care?
You know, I wish I knew that,
but I do not, and I don't remember.
That's a very, very specific question.
Integrally commented on that
whether in 75 we were
tuned into it.
I don't
I don't know, I mean,
it should be on the archival materials
as a beginning to something if it is, but.
In like the scope now or like,
who can view the information.
Or this part of the transcript,
you know, just like you start.
I would think that
that might be where it is, but I don't
I don't know.
I think some of it can be noticed,
a little bit in terms of
if there's a video or not or if it's just
audio, because that also shows
what people are comfortable with.
But also if I get the chance to speak to
any of the students who did field work,
they would probably be able to like,
let me know.
In particular.
Yeah, but I can move to the next question.
This one's kind of
exciting, and I feel like you would have
an interesting viewpoint on it,
but any milestones or turning points?
What pivotal events or decisions shaped
the projects or actions,
and what outcomes came of that?
So anything that stands out to you
during the project, maybe
before those of decisions that were made
that influenced the project in like a
in a certain trajectory?
Well, I think it was definitely the
definitely the equipment.
Nobody was particularly prepared for that.
And once they had it, they did use it.
They really did use it
because that was a that was a good way
to to get to know people.
People enjoyed it.
Most people really enjoyed it.
Were excited about doing it.
I, I would I think we were pretty careful
about giving them a copy of something,
especially if they asked for it. But,
that might, might be and
the two brothers that,
that Tom Adler asked him about that too.
The two brothers that he,
he recorded and, with their friends.
What did he call that?
The timber.
It's a tradition in the know.
That's often what it was.
It was totally.
Tom Adler,
hardware and software.
Well, maybe he put it together with the.
With this?
Know, maybe it wasn't him at all.
This brother.
These two brothers, he took them
to one of the Scott brothers scenes.
He took them to where they like to go.
In Gary.
Oh. My own use of hardware
was best exemplified by my attempt
to produce a statement
about the meaning of the neighborhood
for two young East Chicagoans.
They took me on a tour
of their neighborhood,
directing me to photograph
the scenes in places that they felt
were significant in their lives
the bars where they met girls, the shops
where their parents brought them clothes
in the street corners they hung out on.
So he ended up doing some field work
himself.
That was primarily, equipment,
which I'm not sure
they would have done on their own,
whether they would have bought equipment
smaller, you know, that they would use.
To travel around with. And everything.
Yeah.
If they were doing their own, field work
for the dissertation or whatever.
I couldn't find any specific record
of the specific equipment
that was used, like the name of it,
the brand or the size of it.
I think that's in Adler's.
That might be anomalous.
I will,
you can go back to that one too,
but I know you mentioned the equipment
being such a struggle
and a challenge to work with,
and you mentioned that anecdote as well.
Which leads me to my next question,
which is about stories and anecdotes
that you can share with me.
Could you share 1 or 2 moments?
Sorry.
The thing could you share 1 or 2 moments
that best capture the project?
Spirit or challenges?
And I know you mentioned the challenges,
which is equipment, but what would you,
what kind of stories you have about the
project spirit that would come to mind?
I think what I was surprised in reading
this was that,
well, there probably wouldn't be much
talk about anything that went wrong.
I, I think there was a lot of laughter.
I've said that before.
I think,
and I don't remember any anecdotes.
There were a lot of sayings
I found them in as I was reading
this book to Phil George
had he said, and as we always said,
so there were those kinds of statements
that people made to sum up
a certain situation that had happened.
And that they then they all knew about.
So they might tell that at one of
their meetings or something like that. But
I don't
remember any specific jokes or particular.
Stories or anything.
No particular, you know, nicknames
that came along.
No worries.
Yeah.
Did you get close with the students
as you were,
the coordinator,
or were you more, a like, passage, like.
I was I was present at some of those
recording sessions, especially Jenny's.
I was there for,
I think, for the whole thing.
But I don't remember
if I used the equipment.
I think I would stay away from it.
At this point. You
do you think that the Jenny project
in particular highlights
a particular spirit of that
specific, like people and their community
and everything?
Do you think that would be
one of the major takeaways
from this problem?
I think so there they were all
they were all really good people.
And they
were ones who did get along with Dawson.
I think there was no particular trouble
with them.
But the next one.
So artifacts and evidence
work materials
such as photos, recordings or documents
would you highlight for preservation
and where are they housed?
I know you already spoke.
Yeah,
well, I don't I don't
there's one more thing I didn't find,
and that was the way
the students would be writing.
And that was the folklore forum.
I didn't find that I meant
I was at a friend's house the other day
and was going to look for it,
and then forgot.
It's online though,
so you should be able to find it.
But I just don't know
what number of folklore form it is.
It would be in the 70s, 75, 77.
I know that as
we were discussing, off the record
that all of this collection
seems to be split between multiple
locations like, Indiana University
Archives, Indiana University Northwest,
and there's also some at Lilly Library
in the Bloomington campus as well.
And right before our interview,
you mentioned that
there might be materials
even in Chicago as well.
Do you know more about where
things may have been split up,
or do you have a favorite piece
that, of, I guess the materials
that were collected that you can think of?
I would think that everybody is
I mean, in the book some stood out
better as written pieces than others, but,
certainly
the Serb and Serbian and Croatian
audience had to be very pleased
because there was so much made.
Richard March made of their culture, and
they knew that it had been turned into,
I think even someone
there's a fellow here named Dorian,
and I forget his last name,
but he's a visiting professor
and he does, he does epic.
And he
he showed the Gary Project materials.
So it has
it has continued, to say the least.
Yeah.
In one of his classes.
Oh, you said you didn't show
that Gary project materials.
Oh, interesting.
Well, there is your answer
is a little bit of your question about
what was it being used for it.
Yeah.
If it's found out about it,
it often gets used.
And it's kind of surprising
because these are old, old tapes
and I don't think they ever got upgraded
properly.
The audio, is still, scratchy
sometimes or maybe hard to understand,
but the spirit is still there.
Yeah. Exactly.
Anything else you want to add.
Different. What were we talking about.
Oh what materials do like
send out to you in the.
Yeah. Anything you'd like to highlight.
Well Dawson's book itself is, is, is
like dense. It's dense. Yeah.
There's and there's a lot of people that
he talked to and talked to at some length.
So his chapters,
With the introduction
was his table of contents.
You know.
Illustrations.
Well.
How did you go somewhere
you don't want to fast.
Oh, here.
The mystique of the region itself,
the folklore steel, the ethnics,
which is a very, very rich.
I mean, the churches up
there are so beautiful.
I hope they still are,
black outlooks on crime law,
which which was very big
at that point in the country.
So again, there's that's something
that that is material for today.
I mean, what was it like actually,
back,
back when when this was happening in 70s,
the 70s, this society was changing.
Let's see what he does
of the castrated boy.
Those so legends come in here.
Quite a bit.
Yeah. This is this would all be pertinent.
What he has here.
The heroic bystander.
We still hear about that.
Unwilling witness.
The tricky thief past the policeman.
The bumbling thief.
The tricky intended victim.
A lot of examples here.
Of of those. The hold up foiled
the lucky narrow escape.
The crime carried out the castrated
boy act a,
the attempted abduction.
So he mostly he just
he just puts those stories in here.
He doesn't really do much of a,
An analysis of that, you know,
and I haven't read his.
Let's see what his last
statement in of here.
The last paragraph,
the foray into the region
and thus an urban folklore does
exist and can predictably be
and trapped in every city
in the United States
and in other nations as well.
Most of this
folklore is rooted in episodic experiences
that people relate about themselves
or retell
from the narrations
of friends and acquaintances.
We need not venture onto distant trails
to find folklore.
It is all about us in places of work
and worship,
in our homes and neighborhoods,
projecting our attentions
and anxieties, devilish lusts
and stateliness struggles and ideals.
And that was read from land,
the mill rats.
And the conclusion.
Is the last paragraph in the book.
Oh, interesting material.
There. Two with,
did anything else?
You know.
I'm glad to find that chapter on crime,
Laura.
I think that that that was
that was what we were probably worried
about before going up there.
And then once you once
once they connected with the community,
I think everything got better
because they had they had sort of a
someone who, who vetted for them who is
who will who allowed, who invited them
into a larger, amount of their community.
And I think that made people feel good.
Would you say that the students felt like
welcome into the places that they were?
And for the most.
Part,
I think gradually they would through this.
I mean, the minister that John Hassey
interviewed, for example, I mean, he
he could tell his whole community,
or his old congregation
that this is a good guy or whatever,
bring him into there.
I think that John did something
with the church and music, for example.
So, there were
they opened up doors for them for sure.
And so Dawson did too, and he could take
and they,
they exchanged ideas about who to talk to,
Beforehand, when they were able to.
Do well as, as the project went on
and they learned more.
Yeah.
I don't remember animosity
but maybe there was
and somebody will, there almost had to be.
But I don't.
Anything can happen with field work.
So this next question
feeds into a little bit
of what you were saying already in terms
of challenges and problem solving.
I know you mentioned
a big challenge was the logistics
of working with IU
and then the technology.
Is there anything else you'd like
to talk about in terms of challenges
and how they were solved,
or if they didn't resolve?
I really don't know.
I mean, there were transportation
problems.
I know. It was just.
There were logistics was was not easy
communication in in the region.
I you just tend to
think that there was not that
there was not animosity.
Among the students themselves
or with Dawson particular,
I think these were students who, who,
who had a fairly good relationship
or of good relationship.
And they all had
they were all working on their own stuff.
So they had something else to think about.
I mean, they weren't
didn't feel lost particularly.
I don't think.
So I think it was I don't know,
you know.
Just something to work through
as the project.
Yeah.
How did the communication get resolved
or fixed
or helped along the way with the region.
What do you mean.
I know you mentioned communication and
the region itself was kind of difficult.
How did you getting in touch
with each other.
Yeah. Nobody had cell phone. Phones
at that time.
Right. Exactly.
So you need to get a hold of somebody
or somebody hasn't
shown up to pick you up
because you thought they'd pick you up.
I mean, yeah, there were plenty.
Of situations like. That. Yeah,
because you
could get a really good hint of something.
And then, then you sometimes I think you
sometimes did take off
because if you didn't do it,
you wouldn't get that.
And so somebody might be waiting for you
somewhere,
but you have to make a decision. Yeah.
I mean, seven people working together.
It's not that simple. No.
Trying to,
Everyone's schedules are different.
Everyone's communities are different
that they're working in.
I can understand how that can be. Yeah.
They get a ride from somebody to a place
that they would like to see.
And that's a big region.
It's. It's not a village.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you know the off the top of your head?
The population of Gary at that time?
10,000.
5000.
Surely more than a thousand.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Not much more than that. I would think.
Not to put you on the spot.
No, I think maybe Dawson in turn back
that something about the.
See where he gets to.
You don't know the mystique of the region.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know him.
Yeah.
I was just trying to gauge the scope of.
I really wonder where
we could take our phones out
and probably find out pretty quickly.
I mean, just looking at it at.
The map itself, it.
Doesn't look like it's all that small.
Does he say here he's mentioning
all the different cities, Gary.
He's Chicago.
Hammond, Whiting.
Calumet region.
Oh, here. No,
that's family incomes.
What do you think?
That he would say it somewhere. But
that is a kind of.
Yeah.
Okay.
Boundaries of the region.
It's.
You know, I don't know.
Okay. No worries.
Move on.
So this one's a
the broadest question there.
I say, it's the last question I have
was for the Gary Project in particular.
It is the legacy, legacy and impact.
What lasting impact
send out for participants
are you and the field
and what lessons or advice
would you pass on to future
stewards or coordinators?
I think that it had and had less legacy
than it deserves.
Because these were all very
articulate students.
And yet,
when you think about what the academic way
of, of,
I mean, really the, the,
the job from here should have.
Passed on to the archives.
Archives, first of all.
And I don't think
anybody appreciated that.
We certainly didn't either. That,
getting
the getting made keeping up with the
so keeping up even with the quality
and the nature of the tapes,
updating them as needed.
So they would be there
for, for subsequent generations.
I don't think anybody thought about that.
Put it in the archive and let it be. And,
that's really too bad.
And when you think about academic
conferences, they're,
they're confined to one room in a hotel
where,
you know, at the most 20, 25, 30,
listeners might show up.
For some of them,
this might not be interesting at all.
For others, might pick it up.
But it's nothing's been organized there.
Papers too.
They just appear in a journal somewhere.
So there's there's really no, no
good way to,
the Jenny's Cafe.
Did anybody in the region use it?
You know, nobody followed up on that.
Archivists,
could I think that your archivist
who said that she needed
and was interested in some way to
to disperse
and to let other know about this.
This is true.
The book disappears.
And they go on to their jobs and they do
what their jobs need them to do.
They don't necessarily follow up on those.
So until someone 50 years later.
Yeah.
Randomly comes across this project
and realizes
the scope of it wants to hopefully
bring it full circle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When I'd be I'll be surprised.
I hope you let me know.
I'll be surprised
if the students don't have positive.
But it's possible
I wasn't up there
all the time, and I was also. And,
you know, a.
You know, you have one relationship
with your field,
companions and another one
with some other people.
I will definitely let you know.
If I hear anything.
That was the last of my questions
about the gay project.
Is there anything else you'd like to add
about the project or anything else?
No. No.
Obviously it's brought smiles
and good memories for me and I think.
Reading the books again.
Having the memories for you.
You know missing Aiden and. Yeah.
And you know
not having lost track with Elena
for example I, I, we were good friends
but it happened they, they move and I move
and so on.
So life happens and yeah.
Yeah I'm going to actually end this
recording here
and do a separate
recording for the Dawson section.
If you have anything else to add.
No, I. Think I will end this here.
Good questions. Thank you.